[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
thanks for the nice intro as he said I'm
Melissa
I work at stripe and my talk is going to
be called practice practical solutions
to annoying ml problems feel free to
interrupt me at any time for questions I
like love to hear what people are
thinking during the talk and just for a
tiny bit of context if you're not
familiar stripe is a online payments
company so we provide a payments API
that you can use in a website to accept
credit card payments for your business
online that's not like the main point to
talk but the motivating examples come
from payments and that is why all right
so we were told that we were going to
have practical takeaways for these talks
today and this is the takeaway that I
hope you all come away with there is
hope in production systems they're
really annoying things that happen and
we can't actually do data analysis like
we learned how to do it when we were
taking machine learning classes but my
hope is that you come away with sort of
like a feeling of being able to solve
your problems with creative ways of
using the data and I think this is like
already been highlighted in at least
Nelson's talk he suggested creative ways
of handling his problems even though
they seemed impossible at first so yet
that's my main theme today so I have
three examples here that I saw I want to
talk about that I have seen in my a
couple of years that's right so I'll
just dive right in so the first one is
what I call your model becoming its own
adversary um so this is sort of an
interesting problem there's the subfield
of machine learning called adversarial
machine learning where you have some
model that's predicting some you know
it's classifying things as something
else but you have like an intelligent
entity on the other end that is trying
to fool your model so this is really
common in security this is really common
in fraud detection which is actually
what I work on in machine learning at
stripe so we build models to
automatically decline fraudulent credit
card payments so we have this problem in
a big way but a couple more examples
that we have is personalized advertising
so so what I mean by the model becoming
his own adversary is that once your
model is running in production you don't
have good performance metrics
more so for advertising if you're like
in the simplest case sort of predicting
whether a person will click on an ad you
don't know whether a person will click
on an ad if you don't show it to them
because you don't think they'll click on
it so you're like in this awkward cycle
of not being able to observe how good
your model is and it's the same thing in
my day to day work when we decline a
payment because we think it's fraudulent
we don't ever get a label on it so we
don't actually know if it would have
become fraudulent had we processed it so
it's really difficult to have like real
time monitoring on how good our model is
so I like to summarize this problem as
the models production decision obscures
the outcome label so there are solutions
to this problem this is sort of what I
wanted to come away with like when
you're running a machine learning
production system is your system and you
can manipulate this in sort of any way
you see fit and is ethical so the
solution is to not despair you can
change the production system so I'm
going to go into a detailed example of
how we monitor our production fraud
models for declining transactions in
production so this is an extremely
simplified diagram of what happens when
you make a payment with a stripe
business so there's a charge coming into
the system and our machine learning
models assignments charge some like
fraud probability P and and this is sort
of the ideal system here if the fraud
probability is low enough we're like
that's great this is not fraud like
process the transaction send it to the
network what the customer pipes thing if
the fraud probability is high we say
this is probably fraud that we are not
going to charge the card we send back a
message saying your card was declined so
the idea here is that we then don't have
all the information we need in our
confusion matrix to measure things like
precision recall and false positive rate
which are very interesting on a number
of levels so if the classifier says it
was fraud we will never know
whether or not it was actually fraud
unless someone writes a support ticket
which is quite unreliable as a measure
so
this is a slightly modified version of
our system but it's a system that allows
performance monitoring so we have sort
of the same entry point into the system
you make a charge it gets a fraud
probability if it's low enough we charge
the card with probability one in like a
practical sense we discharge it and if
the fraud probability is high with some
other small probability we'll be like
let's let it through anyway and see
whether it actually comes up as
fraudulent so the probability that will
reverse our decision is some function of
how likely we think it's fraud so we
sort of like let through set like more
charges that we are unsure about for
like very certain that a charge is fraud
we will probably not let it through but
this is basically like an overview of
how we've manipulated our system to
actually get the data that we need so
this is like tiny segments of charges
that we let through anyway and so now I
have a sample of charges that we didn't
decline and we can actually like fill in
our confusion matrix as needed so the
idea here is we don't have exact
accounts but because we sort of like let
through charges with known probability
we can get weighted counts which are
estimated counts so to sort of give an
example of that if I reversed my fraud
decision with probability 5% or
something like that I can sort of say
that this charge that I'm seeing the
outcome of represents is 5% of the
sample of charges like it that I would
have seen so we'll give it a weight of
20 it represents 20 other charges and so
this is sort of reflected in the formula
here we can use inverse probability
weighting for analysis given this system
and so this is the only equation I have
I promise this is basically a formula
for precision using inverse probability
weighting and then this also gives us
like excellent data to use to train new
models this doesn't let us like doesn't
constrain us to sort of like getting
tied down to our old models production
decisions cool
so that was annoying problem one if your
model becomes its own adversary it's
your system you can probably think of a
way to get around that annoying problem
too is when error bar calculations seem
impossible so I'm going to talk about
one of my favorites
that's techniques now which I'm
extremely excited about so an example of
something that people often want error
bars around and it's very difficult to
give them is something like a percentile
so like let's say I want like P 75
compute time and I only have a sample of
the data I want to know like some range
like what can I expect like the the 75th
percentile of the time for this there's
like no statistical way to calculate
like a confidence interval for that you
may have guessed if you measure a models
precision with a sample of data using
inverse probability weighting as before
there is also not really a good
statistical way to get the variance of
that I looked and looked and looked on
the internet for a month and they were
like no it doesn't exist or like maybe
you need to estimate the covariance in
your data which is like extremely
difficult so this is like difficult if
you ever want like arrow bars around
anything more complicated than an
average the solution again is not to
despair I would propose a solution of
bootstrapping
so can we raise our hands like have
people heard of bootstrapping okay that
is like maybe only half of you raise
your hands because you're nervous but uh
anyway this is my favorite thing I'm
going to talk about it anyway so bear
with me if you already know about it we
can just like celebrate beauty of
bootstrapping and I'm going to motivate
it with the sort of inverse probability
weighted performance so we've got this
like original sample of charges the sort
of like you know charges that we
observed and then the the weighted ones
that we let through here's my sample I'm
going to take like one random sample
that's called the bootstrap sample out
of there with replacement with the same
size as the original sample so I'm just
going to like re sample the entire thing
and I'm going to do that a large number
of times maybe 10,000 maybe some other
favorite large number that's fine so I'm
going to take 10,000 resamples then I'm
going to calculate my point estimate so
I'm going to use the precision formula
earlier or from the earlier slide to
calculate the sort
like weighted precision of my model from
the original sample and then I'm going
to do that for all of my 10,000
bootstrap samples as well and then to
make my confidence interval around my
point estimate I'm just going to take
the appropriate percentiles of all of
the sort of sampled performance metrics
that I got from over here so I basically
take the two and a half and ninety seven
and a half percent of the bootstrap
samples I know some people really like
pseudocode this is after all an
engineering conference and part of the
reason I love bootstrapping is because
you can explain it in like 20 lines of
pseudocode so the idea here is that
you're just 10,000 times take the
weighted metric that you want so I think
this one is
I've got precision down here I'm sort of
the second to last line in the loop and
then I just take the appropriate
percentiles and those are my confidence
intervals so here we are not bound by
like formal mathematics we don't have to
wait for someone to sort of like have a
breakthrough
we're generally bound by computing power
and that like sort of large tech
companies like we have a lot of
computers this is something that in like
this day and age we can usually do so
this is sort of one of my favorite hacks
to get around like I need error bars I'm
going to bootstrap them and it's going
to be great we can do this you guys so
this has been really fun
and the other thing is like this makes
almost no assumptions about anything in
your data you don't need normality you
don't need independence that's a big one
I thought about whether all the charges
made on stripe were ever independent in
any way at all I got scared and ran away
it doesn't matter it just doesn't matter
the resampling takes care of like all of
this unfortunate stuff that happens in
the real world and you can just like use
it which is wonderful so that is the
second problem and the third problem
that has motivated this talk it's sort
of answering the question about why a
black box or like somewhat complicated
machine learning model made this made
the decision that it did so again I only
have one example here and it's motivated
by my work but we often get questions
about why our fraud models declined a
specific charge hey I tried to you know
order a ride on a ride-sharing service
card got declined how could you do that
to me I'm a great customer what happened
or we often get something like I saw
this fraudulent charge how did your
models not catch it like why did it not
decline this thing
the reason this is more difficult is
that we use random forests in production
so random forests are basically sets of
several different decision trees so to
actually make a decision about whether
it charged to be classified as fraud or
not fraud it traverses all of these
different decision trees which are fit
using some various accuracy optimization
criteria it traverses all these trees
and when we sort of average the
predictions of the hundreds of trees at
the end out comes the fraud probability
and we predict it using that way this
sort of makes intuitive sense but it's
difficult to explain in English every
traversal through the node of a quite
deep tree and then how on earth I would
average that across many trees so random
forests are like the canonical example
of a black box model so this is sort of
my example of how we might explain try
to explain in English why a random
forest did what it did I have actually
tried to do this before and it does not
go well this is nice for like putting
the splits of the tree in English we
declined your card because the country
of issue didn't meant to the country of
the IP address it was used in and the
number of cards that was you blahblah
okay I can't even read this this is
terrible it makes me sad again the
solution is not to despair so a takeaway
from this particular section of the talk
that I wanted to give you guys was like
even a really naive solution that's like
better than trying to just say it's a
black box and giving up will probably
get you 80% of what your customers want
and so like I think the lesson that I
learned in trying to do this stuff was
like just try it so try the most naive
thing that you can and see what you come
up with so I will go into some of the
details of what we did at stripe so for
some background recently it's ripe we
release a new product where we started
exposing our charge risk levels
to our businesses so if you're
processing payments on stripe all of a
sudden and dashboard you could see the
ones that we thought were fraudulent and
we also like for this product really
really needed to say why so you can now
see like stripe boxes payment because I
thought it was fraudulent and here's the
reason so about a year and a half ago
our team was asked to sort of like I
needed to produce reasons for why you
decline charges so this is the first
thing that we came up with and by we I
mean two of my colleagues the idea is we
take our model and we estimate the fraud
probability for a charge we've been
doing this forever we know how to do
that so for and then for each feature in
the model we would calculate the fraud
probability again so like a sort of sub
fraud probability without that feature
so we'd go through this list of like
however many had hundreds and we just
like calculate the estimated probability
assuming that feature was missing so
then for this list of like hundreds of
features we would go through the list
and find the largest Delta between the
estimated probability that it actually
came out with and all of those lists of
probabilities with the feature missing
and whatever feature like made its
estimate changed the most was the
feature that we were like that's the
most important feature so that's the
explanation that we're going to give for
the model so the feature would be
something like number of charges on this
IP address in the last hour so we do we
translate that into English account
that's something like you know IP
address velocity done and so here's like
another example of our translation this
card number had been used an unusually
large number of times in the past hours
so we would start saying this this
solution was actually like pretty good
so this was like again kind of the the
most naive solution we could think of
and it took a long time it was not like
computationally efficient we would have
some timeouts and you know it wasn't the
best but it's sort of like satisfied
most people's needs but when we decided
to actually like sell this as part of a
product we sort of need to get even
better
so this was
this was funny too because people were
like alright the naive solution it's
pretty good we want to make it like much
much better please do more so this was
like sort of another push in a direction
of like can you do better than the naive
solution and the answer was yes it turns
out people have researched this problem
as well so this is a screenshot of a
paper called the model explanation
system and we actually ended up
implementing this again as v-two of our
explanation models for random force as
straight so so I'll give like a short
detour into what this looks like here so
this is again I believe this is all
written out in the paper and business
how its implemented in our system so the
first thing we do is we take our fitted
model again this is nothing to do with
model training we just like take the
forest that we already have and we get a
list of predicates the idea is like for
every charge that well like it was
fraudulent in the training set we like
trace its path through the forest and
find this like decision tree predicate
for those fraudulent charges we truncate
the paths at like two or three features
or two or three sort of conditions so
it's sort of like was the charge made
from a card country that doesn't match
the IP address country and were there
more than seventeen charges on it in the
last hour that would be like an example
of a predicate that we could get from a
model and like that path led to a
fraudulent charge so we just do this we
just get a list so here's another
example the card was used more than
three times in the last thirty minutes
and the country of card issue does not
match the browser IP address country
that's like an example of a predicate
and we get a long list of these so the
second step is to order the predicate so
we've got this long list like 100 or
whatever and then you order them and the
way that you order them is by precision
and recall which I know are a bit
overloaded as terms but the idea here is
the precision of is what percentage of
charges that satisfy the predicate are
fraudulent so like how precise is the
predicate and recall how many fraudulent
charges is the predicate true for so we
take some like weighted combination of
these things for each predicate and then
we like order them by how good they are
and then this is actually really fast in
production because for an incoming
charge that we think is prod you n't
witch-like
iterate through this list of 100
predicate and stop at the first one that
that charge satisfies so I think this is
actually really cool we don't get
explanations for all of them of course
like that all fraudulent charges and
production will satisfy any of these
sort of paths on the tree but it
actually works pretty well
we now have like interpretive
explanations for like 90% of fraudulent
labels that we have in production and it
runs really quickly so we get many fewer
time outs we have a like reliable
production system etc so the idea here
is that like we took a year and a half
we were pushed several times on this and
random forests are sort of like well
known to be like these are really hard
to explain it's usually not that
important people consider them black
boxes but the idea was like the mindset
should be that like this is solvable we
need it for the product and even if it
went against prevailing wisdom so an
example of sort of like how we worked
hard and like used somewhat simple
solutions to like get around this
problem so yeah so those are the
examples I have again the takeaway
message sort of like we can use cool and
clever data techniques to get around
like problems that are business critical
but sort of difficult from a data
perspective they exist we've been
working on this for like thousands of
years for thousands yeah
thousands thousands of years and we can
get around them so that is all I have I
am happy to take questions both here and
afterward and this is also available in
a blog post version if you are looking
for original version so thank you thank
you
[Applause]
so we have a few minutes for questions
hi good morning
questions how do you work with your data
engineering team so somebody needs to
get give you all that data right how
does that work Andy communication
what's that to you I love this question
cool so I work on the modeling team so I
like train and validate and ship models
we have a couple of infrastructure teams
that work really closely with us so we
have a machine learning infrastructure
team who specifically builds things like
how do I Traverse trees in production
and connect it with a Ruby API they do
those kinds of things and we also have
like a data infrastructure team which my
friend described as slow data like slow
food so they maintain our Hadoop cluster
and sort of our daily ETL pipeline and
we work very closely with them to to
sort of like get the data in the formats
that we need we have like a couple of
supporting teams at Data engineers and
then we have a couple of different data
science teams that work on the modeling
so so there's definitely some separation
but we all know each other well so like
this list of people is people from like
all over like a whole set of this both
teams so yeah so I have a question so
for the predicate list how do you
identify that like have you how do you
decide what goes on there versus what
doesn't on the list I see so I believe
this is something that I haven't worked
like super closely on but I'll do my
best at answering it at a high level so
I believe what happens is there's like a
certain number like on the order of
thousands of charges with positive
labels in our dataset we also have this
fun problem of imbalanced data which I
did not talk about so we've got like
let's say we have 5,000 charges that
have fraud labels in the dataset we
basically like for each of those 5,000
we take how they ended up with a
fraudulent label in the tree and like
the actual like path down the decision
tree forms the predicate so like a
decision tree is basically like a binary
decision at each node and those are the
predicate and then we sort of like how
many predicates do you want in your
explanation like a hundred usually you
want like two so that
people can understand them and so you
just like take all the paths down the
tree that led to fraud and you truncate
them at like two conditions does that
make sense yes okay so a follow-up so if
you weren't using a tree is there a way
that that that that generalizes this one
is somewhat specific to trees since it
like specifically realize I'm like
splits and predicates other models are
easier to explain than trees so like one
thing we used to do so for another fraud
problem at stripe we used to use
logistic regression because we could
basically just like show a list of
coefficients point to the feature or
pointed like predictor that had the
highest coefficient and use that as an
explanation so like other types of
models often don't require as much sort
of like explaining I have not looked
into this for things that are more
complicated in trees like a neural net
how even does it work I think is still
somewhat of an open problem but this
method I think is somewhat specific to
trees but I am optimistic that there are
other ways we could do it for models I
agree with you I do users really care
about like what predicate is shown to
them they do yes especially so it sort
of depend on the business like different
businesses are different it's like
whether they care or not we get we got
asked this so many times that like yes
they do care especially if they have
people writing in to their support site
being like I can't buy anything my card
keeps getting declined on your site yeah
they'll write to us and be like what are
you doing why can't you let my best
friend like order my awesome products
this is really bad which again we like
to really don't like but it also helps
us to like debug problems like oh I see
I see are you taking phone orders all
from the same ip address like we can
sort of like see
you what kinds of problems are being
caused there so yes they do care and we
like often get asked the question like
why did this happen so high I had a well
first of all I wanted to say I also
really love bootstrapping and I use it
for a lot of things but I have an actual
question which is so you talked about
precision and recall and I'm wondering
how how do you decide how to value those
two metrics I love this question so are
you talking specifically about the
explanations or are you talking about
like models in general I guess so you
you said that you were I guess like
weighting these two components to decide
which how to order they'll sort of like
explanations odds yeah I actually don't
know inflection how we decide this but I
know are like general philosophy it's
sort of like in general the way we we
weight precision and recall is like are
the explanations more useful if they
cover a lot of fraud or are they more
useful if like this explanation is like
mostly associated with fraud and so what
we've sort of found anecdotally is like
if we say something that like
intuitively sounds fraudulent it like
people are happier with that explanation
so we tend to wait a little bit toward
precision exactly how much is like less
clear but I think that like specifically
since they're like using explanations in
isolation they want to know that like oh
yeah that does sound like fraud it
sounds like that is like indicative so
we tend to wait toward precision
recalls a little bit less important
because like the fraud can be really
variable like it looks really different
um but it's like all all fraudulent
charges are fraudulent in their own way
or some nice quote like that like having
like one thing that would explain all
the fraud is less important than having
something like oh right that does sound
accurate so we wait towards precision in
terms of how much it's somewhat
arbitrary
thank you